[Musik]
angestiegen
zudem sind 19 personen an der fund des
virus gestorben
auch er ist im kampf gegen das corona
wieses unterwegs grenzwachkorps
feldwebel christian vor
sein auftrag grenzübertritte sperren und
kontrollieren
das ist schwierig solange autolenker die
neuen grenzzone einfach umfahren da sind
jetzt genau oder darauf teile sieht suri
vor
da wird natürlich sichere bis folge mich
logisch mitte ganz akut absperren
ich weiß nicht noch mal damit bestehen
und es wird auch spielen aber irgendwann
ist natürlich jeder vernunft vor der
bevölkerung sagen wir machen das nicht
einfach so nicht bequem geht über die
zugeführte straße vorgestellt zumwinkel
dem virus ein gleiches level
es ist dienstagabend der tag eins nach
dem der bundesrat dies schließe und der
grenze angeordnet hat schweizer hier
ansässige und grenzgänger mit
bewilligung dürfen noch rein
seit den morgenstunden machten die
grenzwächter die meisten grenzen zu auch
jedem zuschauer auf zerfällt
noch fehlen aber die großen betonblöcke
zur sperrung
darum gibt es regelmäßig durchbrüche von
deutscher und schweizer seite
jetzt soll es ein kleinbus richten der
quer in die straße gestellt wird
also wird der tag durch autoclub fordert
ja immer wieder
die tische sind arg sie mir sind auch
sie ein sporadisch besetzt und wenn wir
dann wieder danach ausgesehen dass
barriere vor gemacht worden sind und
darum machte muss jetzt härter mit mafia
boss amerika regelung gibt ja doch der
blieb da bisher nicht beendet am morgen
um hilfe doch und die nächste kippe und
wird das getriebe so lange bis ein halt
wie kritiker und steife mit mobile
straße stehen das kann wirklich
geschafft was wir führen dass wir vor
langer zeit dass man bis man dicht
machen
so haben sie noch nie erlebt man hier
jährlich ca schon seit anfangs winter
habe ich mitglieder des schweizer
grenzwacht groß mehrmals begleitet
da waren die grenzübergänge oft nicht
einmal besetzt und das corolla videos
noch kaum ein thema
ich bin ursprünglich der frage
nachgegangen schützen grenzwächter die
schweiz in zeiten der offenen grenzen
überhaupt noch und wenn ja wie
[Musik]
eine erste antwort habe ich hier
erhalten
bei mobilen einsatzkommando der
eidgenössischen zollverwaltung mek
helvetia eine spezialtruppe die bei
großen fällen zum einsatz kommt
schmuggel oder geldwäscherei zum
beispiel erstmals überhaupt lassen sie
sich filmen
es ist eine übung ein angriff von
kriminellen schmuggler von
betäubungsmitteln die gewaltbereiten
verdächtigten habe man zuvor wochen lang
observiert und auf diesen moment
gewartet
[Musik]
ist das der kickers ausmacht und gerne
auch das ja der adrenalin die jungs weil
die tätigkeit die die möglichkeit den
wir hier haben
das ist dass sie sicherheit was das
motiviere die die leute hier zu kommen
aber jeder weiß das genau denn ich kann
das nicht machen seine ganze karriere
das ist nur noch ein teil von der karte
auf jetzt so gemacht in einem
sonderfonds die sonder formation besteht
aus speziell ausgebildeten grenzwächtern
die anonym bleiben müssen meist
observieren sie als zivilisten getan
sie kommen schweizweit oft zum einsatz
wenn es um bandenmäßigen schmuggel geht
niemand macht das ohne emotionen das ist
normal wir wissen wo wir gehen und sie
wissen auch der verachtung der verein
fotogen wir haben eine solche sache
machen die ganze kunst das kann auch
bringen und wir sind bereit und
trainiert würde das und wir versuchen
das so profi möglich zu machen
wir brauchen leute haben sind multi role
multitasking der können mehr sachen
gleichzeitig machen wir aber auch ein
hier in erster linie mehr hier den
muskel die muskeln trainieren und die
aber deren muss von anfang an stimmen
und das ist sehr schwierigen weg es gibt
selten leute die haben die möglichkeit
mehrere sachen gleiche zeit zu machen
kontrolliert wird nach wie vor
ausländische lastwagen und fahrer wie
hier in basel weil am rhein zwischen der
schweiz und der eu gilt zwar die
personenfreizügigkeit aber die schweiz
gehört nicht zur europäischen zollunion
darum werden hier waren verzollt und
unter anderem die schwerverkehrsabgabe
erhoben
aber dass so mancher fahrer die
anweisungen nicht lesen kann überrascht
nicht
viele kämen von sehr weit her erzählt
uns der zelle revisor große mengen es
gebe stunden vor josef - sind und
schwierigkeiten sind enorm heißt die
kommunikation lassen wir das gestoppt
das ist so wie es mit dem musiker
eigentlich rändern shop ja wenn ich also
lieferungen natürlich musste von selek
musste und den ich hatte einfach nur
lustig wenn die ukraine sind jetzt so
und das indische sprachbarriere nicht
ganz korrekt ticket ist noch nicht gut
die ard stellt kommt dicker weg
fragte drehen kann der goldpreis und
auch
brauchen wir das geld zusammen
der fahrer muss lastwagen gewicht und
aktuellen kilometerstand angeben
auch für die leistungsabhängige
schwerverkehrsabgabe mit der
fortschreitenden digitalisierung wird
sich diese abwicklung in zukunft stark
ändern
magna kommen so nicht sagen
also es gibt für redaktionen es nicht
läuft also wenn sie bevorzugen und
erhaltet brachten sie trächtig natürlich
ist das für die show auf natürliche
produkte und hat kann niemand mit sitz
also heißt dass es zu einer schnellen
und aber wenn es mir spaß macht das von
der oft gehört und trotzdem hat der
leiter ob man die grenze
täglich fahren rund 20.000 lastwagen in
die schweiz
die zöllner können nur einen bruchteil
der ladungen kontrollieren ziel ist es
den schmuggel zu verhindern dann mit dem
staat nicht soll einnahmen verloren
immerhin betragen die gesamteinnahmen
der eidgenössischen zollverwaltung
jährlich über 20 milliarden franken
soll fachmänner wie lukas spüre
kontrollieren aber auch ob lastwagen und
fahrer fahrtüchtig sind viele chauffeure
hörten die ruhezeiten nicht einhalten zu
denken haben manipulieren unterschrieben
und das geht mit dem doppelten kabel das
wegen der manipulation schaffen
oder stößt richtig dass es einfach das
im prinzip der vater über den richtig
funktioniert das einfach abschaltet und
tablet-computer fahren um
das große vorführung
saic finden das geht häufig
das geht häufig jahre also sich aber
schwierig zum findet sich meistens
elektronisch gesteuerten 10 am
montagabend verschieden der vorteil wo
das alte malte
haben sie die teilsperre der medizin
geworden
das hat mir ist nach wiederum teil ist
auf der nordstraße maximum
und wenn das natürlich manipulieren von
einem viel größeren schritten um das
letzte glied
das muss man sehen
der mindestlohn harmonisch und was die
mannschaft und wenn wir ihnen den usa
abnahme welt weiß dass seine schafe fünf
bis acht unter par die und monaten einer
nach der 2 3 und frauen für das machen
die systematischen personenkontrollen an
der grenze gibt es seit schengen nicht
mehr
aber es gibt mobile einsätze im
sogenannte rückwärtssuche in der
bodenseeregion eine sprung verhandlungen
mit hilfe von armee helikopter und
wärmebildkamera und das in
zusammenarbeit mit der deutschen
bundespolizei im grenzraum deutschland
schweiz auf verschiedene control bled
kontrollstelle betriebe mit absichtlich
vom flair team dass man die kontrolle
über woche
wir haben zu der allgemeinen lage ist
momentan arbeitet das datum dass das
andere wiederum sind im ganzen ruhm
ganzen schweiz aber natürlich grenzen
der tormann mit der kontrolle werde
durch ihre guten grund dass sie halt
machen klar und so wird über grenzen und
spricht sie denn mit eine träne fassen
oder einfach schnell los
[Musik]
zusammen mit einem halben dutzend mobile
grenzwächter fliege ich übers deutsch
schweizerischen grenzgebiet die kamera
unter dem helikopter liefert auch nachts
beste bilder ein taktischer vorteil
gegenüber möglichen kriminellen sagt
einsatzleiter vor ort zum beispiel wenn
ein auto kurz vor der kontrolle wieder
ab das wort
immer wieder mal landet der helikopter
die grenzwächter unterstützen so mobile
polizei kontrollen am boden
es sind kurze kontrollen aber mit großen
teams
man wolle den überraschungseffekt nutzen
mit stichproben die polizisten stoßen so
oft auf einkaufstouristen mit
schmuggelware verkehrssünder oder
betrunkene
immer mit dabei ist aber die hoffnung
auf den ganz großen farm
auf einmal haschisch geruch kommt
hinterher
also nachdem ihn die ganze karte nicht
gesehen aber jetzt zwischen totaler
durch das cover drauf internet
aber woher kommt die luft
offensichtlich aus diesem auto die
sicherheitskräfte kontrollierten die
insassen und neben proben die sie gleich
vor ort analysieren
es wird sich herausstellen cbd haschisch
nichts kriminelles die zwei arbeiten in
einem legalen hand flaggen heißt es aber
das gibt befriedigung in dem job aber
natürlich macht es spaß wenn man ein
fall hat wo also wenn wir dran also
kriminaltouristen wie es für ein
mehrseitiges kann und das dann weiß man
bis kurz gemacht und das macht natürlich
spaß die großen fälle sind aber eher
selten
und doch das eine oder andere finde man
bei solchen razzien immer sagt
einsatzleiter vor ort wieder reichlich
mittelbereich fahrens ohne führerschein
der autor hat liegen
mittel die pedale tritt
oder aus straßenfeste patrioten fal si
[Musik]
das bedeutet dass weitere sicherheit
das hält sicher aber auto sportlicher
gerechtigkeit sie das beste alle gleich
beatmet zurück bei mobilen
einsatzkommando helvetia geübt wird der
schnelle zugriff auf einem parkplatz
nach wochen teils monatelange um
situation
die zugriffe müssen sehr schnell gehen
zum schutz des verdächtigten aber auch
den eigenen einsatzkräfte
wir wollen ein bisschen seine
persönliche sphäre so ein bisschen
schützen und für uns ist wichtig wenn
wir so schnell wie möglich die personen
auf dem sich von die leute weg nehmen
das ist ein bisschen eine von der wohnt
also so schnell wochen das nimmer mit
dem handy ist genau das das wäre diddy
diddy diddy die perfekte sage ich lage
für uns man müsste schon als kind gerne
räuber und polizist gespielt haben sagt
einer
aber mir kommt hier auch der gedanke an
ausländische sondereinheiten die
manchmal von der rechtsextremen kreisen
infiltriert werden
es gibt in anderen ländern immer die
diskussion das rechte oder rechtsextreme
menschen in solche sondereinheiten
wollen wie ist das hier bei ihnen bei
uns ist das sicher kein thema wir haben
leute der wunsch krümmling sind gute
schweizer nachkommen von die ganze teile
der welt sie haben leute von asia von
von afrika von südamerika ich bin ein
gutes produkt von der schweizerin
integration sowie uns dieses problem wie
annie einmal stattfinden wegen wir haben
eine multikulturelle
zeigen
stand in der reinheit und bei uns das
funktioniert sehr gut wir sind für den
rallye ist es aber sicher nicht
rechtsextrem das ist dass das gar nicht
garantieren gibt es da kontrollen und
sich ja wie auch seine sicherheit
überprüfen wir in der einheit kommen
sonst bei gw kassel sicherheit überprüft
und noch mehr wir haben ein anderes
level von sicherheit kontrolle bei der
einheit und der assistent bei jungs das
sind sachen wo wir erklären
auch mit der psychologe der sonst eher
bei uns ist alles ist geklärt
der bahnhof prix im oberwallis an diesem
tag auch noch vor der korona zeit steht
die kontrolle eines internationalen
zuges an
also ich begrüße euch zu station
kontrolle dass bello 220 den weg wir
werden den ein reisezug der von venedig
nach paris reist kontrollieren im moment
die lage von uns ist klar dass wir in
diesem zug fälschungen mit fälschungen
rechnungen müssen
es sind im poster also nicht zustehende
ausweise oder auch visums die oft
gefälscht werden
was vielleicht ein bisschen als
spezielles control thema ob sich ihr
leiden eine zollkontrolle durchführen
in der zur kontrolle halten wir auch auf
verbote und sowohl ein und aus und
durchfuhr verboten worden sprich
betäubungsmittel waffen und gefälschte
das geld oder wertsachen unsere augen
halten also im fall eines
fluchtversuches bitte eigens mit über
die pflanzen auch wenn andere mittel wir
werden dort ein dispositiv aufziehen mit
kantonspolizeien kilian zusammen und
direkt werden wir den bahnhof über auch
kann ein bisschen größe nicht dass wir
irgendwie ein personenunfall erhalten
[Musik]
juli
[Applaus]
[Musik]
versteckt
an diesem tag die französischen
eisenbahner dem streik und darum auch
weit weniger passagiere unterwegs als
sonst
erwischt hat es bei der kontrolle einen
jungen albaner der 46-jährige moment
rüber es müssten gut mit der person rede
was sie seit wurde
natürlichkeit die dokument ohne dauer
hat die sind nicht günstig für
aufenthalt in china
das heißt so was man jetzt gesehen da
für die tolle werte sind genügsam mit
dem reisepass mit rund ums reisen
sondern im schengen raum macht dieses
land aktivitäten ist autorisierter tag
das heißt er darf sich mit ja unter den
schengen-staaten aufhalte
[Musik]
das hat der show quiz das hat er also
der sonic seit oder das war ja das ist
natürlich zentrums im real da machen die
control und intensiv prüfen
aber nicht nur zollrechtlich sondern
eben die kontrolle machen machen wir sie
umfassen
der mann wird ein paar stunden später
nach italien zurückgeführt
illegale grenzübertritte haben in den
letzten jahren stark abgenommen
die eu und mit ihr die schweiz regelt
ihr der außengrenze stärker an
kritiker sprechen von der festung europa
dennoch müssen grenzwächter auch hier
immer wieder mal menschen zurückweisen
etwas müssen wir für ein typ sich also
ich erzählte mir ich war die zufriedene
renner war wodurch winkte persönlich
verschiedenen mir ist natürlich auch sie
das
der job der bietet so viel 5 gb oder
interessant manchmal lustig manchmal
latour ich solle
und typisch dann genau in dem moment um
raum schaffen ist da ist mancher der
konzentrierten sich auf seine arbeit und
und vielleicht machen die jetzt können
wir ein schau gedanken oder manchmal
auch leicht frivole die jedem fall
natürlich schön sind
sind sie da
die migrationsfrage steht in diesen
tagen nicht im brennpunkt
die schweiz hat sich wegen des corona
virus abgeriegelt auch nachbar
deutschland hat die pforten geschlossen
das heißt wir sind am grenzposten ras
sorgen einer der wenigen die noch offen
sind an das neue regime wird man sich
gewöhnen müssen
auch ein schweizer imker der seine
bienen jenseits der grenze in
deutschland hat
die reise gehen auf ein haus
sie wisse dass in reno experte berlin
aus gesehen als ich den regen an
bedienen wird ist schwer aber wenn es
jetzt zu libyen könnte das projekt auch
machen aber sie scheint in die natur
wird kritischer später werdet fuhr mit
dem auto
er muss umkehren
wie lange die grenzen zu bleiben darüber
wollen sie hin nicht spekulieren aber
irgendwann müssen sich auch die
grenzwächter bildet mit handschlag
voneinander verabschieden
traute
später da ja dass sie den film zum thema
schweizer grenzwächter empfehlung war
schlussendlich ein besonders süßer kurs
das wir erwartet aber wegen der
geschichte mit dem corona virus aber das
macht darüber du immer spannend jetzt
wenn der frage oder kommentare die fahne
geschrieben und sie wird aber nicht
freuen wenn der infokanal abonnieren
er ist der auftakt findet immer
spannende sache